[Music]
twenty-eight teams marks the tenth year
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Ironman came out in 2008 which is crazy
I mean can you believe it yes I can
I've got yacked like I've been Phil
Coulson for a long time now you have as
as an OG how have you seen the Marvel
Universe changed over the past decade it
was pretty special to be on the set on
Ironman and just see having read those
comics as a kid seeing the way Robert
Downey and Gwyneth and Jeff Bridges and
just every element of that was and we're
really what jon favreau designed which
was this very dramatic but at the same
time very funny Marvel model I knew
something special was happening on the
other hand Kevin Feige Lutie Esposito
Jeremy latch them they the world of
Marvel the track record has just been
unbelievable everything's good and an
awful lot of them are truly great I just
saw thor ragnarok and I was blown away I
know and I'm always excited to see the
next thing what they're doing is really
special I love that it's all one giant
story that connects and the guardians
show up and there's Thor and it's
amazing and she's been really exciting
to be on the other to be the first one
through the door of the television world
of it and to see that universe expand to
where you've got the cool stuff on
Netflix that I adore Daredevil and
Jessica Jones and Luke Cage and then I'm
really proud of what's going on with our
show which was kind of an odd marriage
at first a network version of Marvel but
ABC and Marvel found a way to really let
this feel more and more like a Marvel
show and I feel like our writers have
done an incredible job of plumbing the
depths of the Marvel Universe for stuff
that we could use that would work with
our show and done the thing that I've
never really see done which is every
season I feel like it's better than the
one kid that came before well you talked
about you know you can absolutely
believe that it's been ten years is that
something that you think about
in long terms of plane Colson for a lot
longer or do you see yourself hang it up
the eye shield yeah right I feel lucky I
feel lucky every day that I get to do it
cuz it's fun and it's not just you know
I'm in a courtroom every day some days
we're doing giant fights and wider work
and other days very dramatic stuff and
visual effects stuff it's been a long
journey we just shot the hundredth
episode of this show and and yet I also
feel really grateful so if they came to
me and said listen Olsen maybe doesn't
live I would feel like I've had I'd be
hard to regret anything and you'd be
like but does he come back because we've
done that
[Music]